[Musique]
un
mélange entre le monde des sorciers
époque médiévale et culture japonaise
c'est la recette proposée par le geek
festival aux clayes-sous-bois pour sa
première édition les fans ont répondu
présent
pourquoi pas trouver des gens qui font
du cost est comme moi pour faire des
duos et cetera c'est l'occasion du coup
de main portée de crosse qu en extérieur
parce que parfois on ne sait pas
forcément quand c'est pas dans le cas
d'une convention on voit souvent des
coiffeurs différents laisse sans voix
des personnages qu'on aime bien
les gens
rentrent à vide entre concours de
cosplay et échanges entre passionnés et
animations les festivités se sont
déroulées en extérieur un vrai parti
pris des organisateurs voulaient se
différencier de la région parisienne où
on est dans des grandes salles où tout
le monde se marche quasiment dessus on a
quelques stands du projet d'animation
qui vont vendre des frites
antijaponaises des kimonos des
chaussettes plein de petits goodies on a
du coup aussi des stands d'illustration
on a un éditeur de mangas qui ferment
gars afro basket mythe ça parle de deux
jeunes adolescents cinq alémaniques qui
vont parcourir l'afrique donc explique
amar dans le monde ya donc c'est la plus
créative pour devenir des gardiens du
gardien c'est des protecteurs des hommes
comme tout grand rendez vous il faut son
lot de stars aux geeks up festival c'est
elle et chris evans et margot robbie
version française je pensais que la
vraie vedette c'était la personne à
l'écran où nous on était un peu
accessoire j'allais dire est en fait pas
du tout pas du tout c'est très
complémentaire et les gens aiment
beaucoup ça ça fait vraiment un retour
critique qui est hyper hyper
enrichissant et constructif pour nous
et puis c'est tellement de gentillesse
et c'est toute la journée que le soir
c'est ont l'impression qu'on est chargé
à bloc pour un mois ou deux la jusqu'au
prochain moment de rencontre et c'est
très agréable et même sans compter les
multiples rôles interprétés par les deux
doubles heures l'événement a accueilli
environ 1000 visiteurs lors du week end